we have been following over the last 48
hours a rush to virtue signal by
republicans about the united states
border with mexico
even governors
senators
members of congress from landlocked
non-border states
are jumping in on the bandwagon why well
because as joni ernst said in a video
which we'll look at in a moment
every state is now a border state there
first of all we have to understand at
the top level what's going on here
very little has changed
under the biden administration since the
trump administration as far as
immigration goes
what has changed well as the pandemic
has eased depending on how you look at
it
mobility has re-increased
and a lot of the pent-up demand from
2020 of folks who did not move
physically is now ramping up that is
responsible for part of the increase we
are seeing in folks trying to cross
um
seasonality plays a role we all we
talked about that in the spring in the
spring seasonality plays a role compared
to winter months under trump that are
the basis for comparison
uh but very little has actually changed
the haitian situation has not been
particularly dealt with by joe biden but
that that's uh um
we don't think it's been dealt with well
in a different way than republicans
don't think it's been dealt with well
but republicans want to make it seem as
though joe biden has opened the border
and is saying come on in to whoever the
hell wants to come in and i'm going to
play some clips for you here of a
variety of different republicans jumping
in on the action here is senator joni
ernst she's from iowa
iowa a landlocked state nowhere near the
u.s mexico border listen to what she had
to say the reality is that every state
is now a border state
all of the issues that are affecting
texas and those that are seeing this
sweep of illegals coming across the
border all of those issues are now
facing every other state yeah so the
argument that they are making is
people might come in through a border
state but then they they use extremely
dehumanizing language like animals
cockroaches they just spread into all
these different states
this is the gist this is the imagery um
she goes on to go full trump in her
fear-mongering talking about rapists
that's just
they love talking about rapists when
they talk about the border with an
extraordinary number of people crossing
the border illegally of course we are
going to have rapists we're going to
have um those that are terrorists we're
going to have other bad people entering
so if that vocabulary sounds familiar to
you it should because it's the exact
same vocabulary vocabulary with which
donald trump opened his 2016 uh
republican uh uh primary campaign for
president really in 2015 is when he
actually started it
then we go this one's just amazing ted
cruz puts on a performance there was a
shooting yesterday
in texas
and um ted cruz
has one of these incredible performances
where he does his sort of like fake
genuine very somber
and then pivots directly from the school
shooting to just go after joe biden for
the border it's it's jaw it's weirdly
jarring
and there have been far too many of
these at far too many schools and so
we are grateful for the courage and
heroism the first responders
and we are hopeful that that all of the
students
or individuals
who may have been injured will will come
through
and survive right
we're here today
because of the biden border crisis
that continues to rage on the southern
border yeah
all right so we dropped in there to hear
a little bit what a transition folks
what a transition and a very similar
dynamic actually down at the border
republican texas governor greg abbott
went went down to the border they set up
an entire dog and pony show with you can
see in the background if you're watching
i see a chopper or two tanks i think
armored vehicles of different kinds
and in this clip you're going to hear
greg abbott
talk about the influx of migrants at the
southern border
take a listen
this is
one of if not the most urgent matter
that we're facing in the united states
at this time and it's time for the bite
administration to wake up and get on the
job and do its job to protect the
sovereignty and safety of the united
states of america now remember
very little has changed this urgency is
a very concocted fabricated essentially
out of thin air what changed a democrat
in the white house that's what changed
the we we have had an ebb and flow on
this issue we have no permanent status
for daca recipients we have not um uh
done all sorts of other types of reform
that have been discussed for a very long
time
and this is a virtue signaling uh party
that they are essentially throwing for
themselves um greg abbott was actually
just to kind of close the loop on the
school shooting as well greg abbott was
asked about the school shooter and he
said listen this is not about gun
control because the school shooter
possessed the gun illegally anyway
governor are you concerned that the the
new law of constitutional carry is
sending the wrong message to young
people could see
so very importantly
with regard to the school shooting that
took place today as well as with
really any school shooting that i'm
aware of
the gun that was possessed by the
shooter was possessed illegally
and we will make sure that laws are
enforced and those who act illegally
will be held accountable so listen first
of all i'm almost positive that we not
long ago
we have so many school shootings in this
country it's hard to keep track but i'm
pretty sure that under the trump
administration
i'm not blaming trump i'm just saying
during the time trump was president um
there was a school shooting where the
guns were legally owned although maybe
that was the one
in california
at the
bart station there's so many shootings
in the united states that it's difficult
to keep track
but the point is they always go they go
listen the laws don't matter because the
shooters will just get the guns
illegally but as we've said many times
before
if you have more uniform laws you
make it more difficult to just go to the
neighboring place to get the guns
illegally because there are simply fewer
guns around at some point the illegal
gun was a legal gun and then something
happened
you know they like to say well if guns
are stolen that's no one's fault but of
course we know there are many other ways
that these guns ultimately end up in the
hands of people who do wrong with them
so on the shooting the normal stuff we
would expect
but this border craze they all of a
sudden have fox news with the chirons
and the lower thirds about panic panic
panic at the border
remember that
very modest changes
uh in terms of circumstances from trump
to biden but what's changed is biden's a
democrat trump was a republican and now
republicans want to talk about this let
me know your thoughts you can find me on
twitter at deepakman and remember that
on tuesday october 19
we are doing a live viewer town hall at
6 00 pm eastern it will be streamed live
only on the second youtube channel
pacman live find it at youtube.com
pacman live and uh 6 p.m eastern tuesday
october 19.
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over twenty thousand five
star reviews and best of all if you
don't love it you'll get one hundred
percent of your money back because they
stand behind their product you've got
nothing to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent off and free shipping
when you go to four sigmatic dot com
slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video